Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The fiendish treatment of German Jews was always to be anticipated by those who took the trouble to read Mein Kampf, which is plastered with anti-Semitic abuse. To some extent, the persecution of Jews in Germany, and since the spring in Austria also, may have been employed to distract attention from the failure of Nazism to supply guns as well as butter, while their confiscated property is doubtless a convenient aid to depleted Nazi coffers. But antisemitism and persecution of Catholics are not a mere exhibition of crude
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。对于那些费心阅读过《我的奋斗》的人来说，纳粹对德国犹太人的残酷对待早就在预料之中，因为书中充斥着反犹太主义的谩骂。在某种程度上，德国（以及自春季以来的奥地利）对犹太人的迫害，可能被用来转移人们对纳粹未能同时提供“大炮与黄油”的关注，而没收他们的财产无疑也是充实纳粹枯竭国库的便捷手段。但反犹太主义和对天主教徒的迫害并非仅仅是粗俗的
medievalism. Their purpose is to root out of the German people any allegiance, not only political, but even spiritual and intellectual. Other than that, to the Führer. That was the Yorkshire Post on the 14th of November 1938. Dominic, we left the story of the ratcheting up of Nazi persecution of the Jews in 1936, in the wake of the Berlin Olympics, when the Nazis had tidied up Berlin, had removed some of the more obviously anti-Semitic public notices, had allowed Jews to compete in the German Olympic team. But by 1938, that has darkened very, very seriously to the degree that it is becoming apparent to people, not just within Germany, but as we heard outside Germany, in Britain, in America, across the world.
中世纪主义的表现。其目的是从德国人民心中根除任何效忠对象，不仅是政治上的，甚至包括精神和思想上的，除了对元首的效忠之外。这是1938年11月14日的《约克郡邮报》。多米尼克，我们上次讲到纳粹在1936年柏林奥运会后加剧对犹太人迫害的故事，当时纳粹清理了柏林，撤除了一些明显的反犹太公共告示，并允许犹太人参加德国奥运代表队。但到了1938年，情况已经变得非常、非常糟糕，以至于不仅在德国国内，正如我们所听到的，在德国之外的英国、美国以及世界各地，人们都已察觉到了这一点。
What is the process by which we get from 1936 to 1938? Well, that's the story that we'll be telling in the first half of this episode, Tom. Just a quick word on that editorial. So that was written just a few days after the Reichskristallnacht, the Night of Broken Glass, as we call it in English, the great state-sponsored pogrom against the Jews in Germany. And actually, the interesting thing about that Yorkshire Post editorial is it gets a lot of things absolutely right, doesn't it?
我们是如何从1936年走到1938年的？嗯，这就是我们在本集前半部分要讲述的故事，汤姆。关于那篇社论，简单说两句。那是写在“水晶之夜”（Reichskristallnacht，我们在英语中称之为“碎玻璃之夜”）之后几天，那是德国历史上由国家支持的针对犹太人的大规模大屠杀。事实上，《约克郡邮报》那篇社论有趣的地方在于，它在很多方面都说得非常准确，不是吗？
It says that the scale of this attack could have been anticipated if you'd read Mein Kampf. It talks about how the Nazis like to ratchet up the anti-Semitism to distract from the fact that they are struggling to provide guns as well as butter. So that's a theme that you get from the histories by Adam Tooze or Richard Evans or something. It talks about the Nazi appetite for plunder of Jewish businesses, the confiscated property. It rightly says that the anti-Semitism of the Nazis is not just what it calls crude medievalism, that it's different in character.
它提到，如果你读过《我的奋斗》，就能预见到这场袭击的规模。它谈到了纳粹如何喜欢煽动反犹太主义，以转移人们对他们难以提供“大炮与黄油”这一事实的注意力。所以，这是你在亚当·图兹（Adam Tooze）或理查德·埃文斯（Richard Evans）等人的历史著作中会看到的主题。它谈到了纳粹对掠夺犹太企业和没收财产的渴望。它正确地指出，纳粹的反犹太主义不仅仅是它所称的“粗俗的中世纪主义”，其性质是不同的。
But it's totalitarian. I mean, it gets the character of totalitarianism very accurately. It gets one thing wrong, I would say, which is that it brackets it with the persecution of Catholics. Now, of course, there is tension between the Nazis and the Catholic Church. I mean, that would be a wonderful episode of the rest of history in itself. But perhaps what the Yorkshire Post doesn't quite get is the character of Nazi anti-Semitism
它是极权主义的。我的意思是，它非常准确地抓住了极权主义的特征。我认为它有一点说错了，那就是它将这种迫害与对天主教徒的迫害相提并论。当然，纳粹与天主教会之间确实存在紧张关系。我的意思是，这本身就是《历史的余味》中精彩的一集。但也许《约克郡邮报》没有完全理解纳粹反犹太主义的本质，
is so different from all the other Nazi prejudices. But I think also the idea that persecuting the Catholic Church is a feature of the Middle Ages isn't entirely accurate. No, I guess not. Well, I mean, listen,
它与其他所有纳粹偏见截然不同。但我认为，认为迫害天主教会是中世纪特征的观点也不完全准确。不，我想不是。好吧，我的意思是，听着，
we could spend the next hour nitpicking the Yorkshire Post, but that's not the aim of the episode. So, yes, how do we get from 1936, from the Olympics to Kristallnacht? Well, what happens is that after the apparent stasis of 1936 into 1937, the Nazi sort of anti-Semitism machine, as it were, the engine of anti-Semitism starts to crank up again towards the end of 1937. I mean, there are multiple reasons. One is obviously the impetus is always there. It's always been there kind of latently. But also, the Nazi high command at this point are very conscious that war is coming. They want war to come. They have a four-year plan
我们可以花下一个小时来挑剔《约克郡邮报》，但那不是本集的目的。所以，是的，我们是如何从1936年的奥运会走到“水晶之夜”的呢？嗯，发生的事情是，在1936年到1937年看似停滞的状态之后，纳粹的反犹太主义机器，或者说反犹太主义的引擎，在1937年底又开始运转起来。我的意思是，原因有很多。一个是显然动力一直都在。它一直以某种潜在的方式存在。但同时，纳粹最高指挥部此时非常清楚战争即将来临。他们希望战争到来。他们有一个四年计划，
to prepare the Nazi economy for war. They are eyeing up Austria, Czechoslovakia, Poland, preparing to strike into the East to win the living space that they think they need. They think the conflict is inevitable. And it's very important for Hitler that what he sees as the enemy within is eliminated before he can take on the enemy without. But Dominic, when you say the enemy within, I mean, this is often used today. It kind of implies, I don't know, separatists within a nation state or something like that. But that's not quite what it means in this context, is it? Because it's more biological. It's an idea of an infection within the body. Yes, exactly. You're a boxer going to a world championship bout, but you have a virus that has made you weak, so you need to be cured of it.
为纳粹经济备战。他们盯着奥地利、捷克斯洛伐克、波兰，准备向东方出击，以赢得他们认为自己需要的生存空间。他们认为冲突是不可避免的。对于希特勒来说，在对付外部敌人之前，消除他眼中的“内部敌人”非常重要。但多米尼克，当你提到“内部敌人”时，我的意思是，这在今天经常被使用。它有点暗示，我不知道，民族国家内部的分裂分子之类的。但在这种语境下，这并不是它的真正含义，对吧？因为它更具生物学色彩。这是一种体内感染的观念。是的，完全正确。你是一个要去参加世界冠军赛的拳击手，但你感染了一种让你虚弱的病毒，所以你需要治愈它。
That's the sort of medical metaphor that the Nazis employed. That's exactly it. They need to purge this from the system. That's how Hitler is thinking. Now, even at this stage, 1937, the Nazis are thinking in extraordinarily ambitious terms. So in November 1937, Goebbels has a long conversation with Hitler and afterwards he writes in his diary these words, the Jews must get out of Germany, indeed out of Europe altogether. That will take some time yet, but it will and must happen. The leader is firmly resolved upon it.
这就是纳粹所使用的那种医学隐喻。正是如此。他们需要从系统中清除这种东西。这就是希特勒的思维方式。现在，即使在1937年这个阶段，纳粹的思维也极其宏大。因此，在1937年11月，戈培尔与希特勒进行了长时间的谈话，事后他在日记中写下了这样的话：犹太人必须离开德国，甚至完全离开欧洲。这还需要一些时间，但它会而且必须发生。元首对此已坚定决心。
I mean, kind of interesting use of words though there, get out of Europe. but it will and must happen. The leader is firmly resolved upon it. I mean, kind of interesting use of words though there, get out of Europe, not be eliminated from Europe. So is this reflective of the SS program to force Jews to emigrate to Palestine and so on? Yes. Because as you said last time, the great engine for doing this is the SS, is Himmler. The SS are dreaming of this great territorial empire in which they will be the new racial elite. Yeah. They increasingly regard kind of Nazi racial policy as their own private domain. Because the SS are intellectually elite, aren't they? As well as racially elite,
我的意思是，那里用词很有趣，“离开欧洲”。但它会而且必须发生。元首对此已坚定决心。我的意思是，那里用词很有趣，“离开欧洲”，而不是“从欧洲被消灭”。那么，这是否反映了党卫军强迫犹太人移民到巴勒斯坦等地的计划？是的。因为正如你上次所说，实现这一目标的伟大引擎是党卫军，是希姆莱。党卫军梦想着这个伟大的领土帝国，他们将成为新的种族精英。是的。他们越来越将纳粹的种族政策视为自己的私人领地。因为党卫军是知识精英，不是吗？正如他们也是种族精英一样，
as they themselves would see it. Yeah. They're more likely to be university educated, for example, than other Nazi groups. So they are intellectuals, a lot of them. I mean, they're not just mindless thugs. These are people who are providing intellectual rationalisations for what they are going to be doing. you said a couple of episodes ago himla for example is going and doing all these archaeological digs and searching for artifacts and dabbling in occult theories and stuff and he is a good example of somebody who regards this as not just a question of policy it's a question of existential life and death it's apocalyptic struggle is coming he tells s SS leaders, November 1938, we are facing an ideological struggle with Jewry, Freemasonry, Marxism, and the churches of the world. And he says, you know,
正如他们自己所认为的那样。是的。例如，与其他纳粹组织相比，他们更有可能是受过大学教育的。所以他们是知识分子，他们中的很多人。我的意思是，他们不仅仅是无脑的暴徒。这些人正在为他们即将要做的事情提供知识上的合理化解释。你几集前说过，希姆莱例如去进行所有这些考古挖掘，寻找文物，涉足神秘理论等等，他是一个很好的例子，说明有人认为这不仅仅是一个政策问题，这是一个生存的生死问题，世界末日的斗争即将到来，他告诉党卫军领导人，1938年11月，我们正面临一场与犹太人、共济会、马克思主义和世界各教会的意识形态斗争。他说，你知道，
the Jew has to be driven out. Because the Jews are responsible for all those things. Yes, exactly. I mean, Freemasonry, Marxism, and the churches, they are all Jewish. Exactly. And they think when war comes, those two questions are inextricably coupled. The Jews in Germany and war in Europe. That we cannot win the war in Europe unless we have dealt with the issue of the Jews in Germany. So spring 1938, you have the Anschluss, which we did in a previous episode, the incorporation of Austria with its large Jewish minority, particularly in Vienna, into the Reich. And the number of Jews who have now been absorbed into the Reich make up for the number of Jews who've emigrated from Germany.
犹太人必须被赶走。因为犹太人要对所有这些事情负责。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，共济会、马克思主义和教会，它们都是犹太人的。完全正确。他们认为当战争来临时，这两个问题是不可分割地联系在一起的。德国的犹太人和欧洲的战争。我们如果不解决德国犹太人的问题，就无法赢得欧洲的战争。所以1938年春天，发生了“德奥合并”（Anschluss），我们在之前的一集中讲过，奥地利及其庞大的犹太少数群体（特别是在维也纳）被并入帝国。现在被吸收到帝国中的犹太人数量，弥补了从德国移民出去的犹太人数量。
Exactly. So as far as if you're an anti-Semite, you're back to square one, effectively. You've got now the same number of Jewish fellow citizens, though you don't think of them that way, as you started with. And so it's at this point that you have a new sort of phase in the anti-Jewish terror. So it's at this point in the spring of 1938 that almost all remaining Jewish doctors and lawyers lose their licenses. It's at this point that the Nazis unleash violence against synagogues and Jewish cemeteries. So the Great Synagogue in Munich is demolished in June 1938. The Great Synagogue in Nuremberg is demolished at the same time that summer in August.
完全正确。所以如果你是一个反犹主义者，你实际上又回到了原点。你现在拥有的犹太同胞数量，和你开始时一样多，尽管你并不把他们视为同胞。所以正是在这一点上，你有了反犹太恐怖的新阶段。所以正是在1938年春天，几乎所有剩下的犹太医生和律师都失去了执照。正是在这一点上，纳粹对犹太教堂和犹太墓地发动了暴力。所以慕尼黑的大犹太教堂在1938年6月被拆除。纽伦堡的大犹太教堂在同年的那个夏天，即8月被拆除。
Which has an incredible symbolic resonance because, of course, Nuremberg is the centre of the rallies. It's been enshrined by the Nazis as the embodiment of everything that a racially pure Germany should be. So to have the synagogue standing there, and it's a huge structure with a great dome, very kind of contrary to the medieval architecture of the old city. To Nazis, it's a standing affront. But at the same time, for anyone who is alert to the history, not just of recent antisemitism, but of antisemitism reaching back to the Middle Ages, the destruction of that synagogue is a terrible symbolic moment because there'd been two previous synagogues. Both had been destroyed in antisemitic pogroms, the first one in 1349. So in the context of the Black Death Death so that sense of plague again and anti-Semitism being kind of
这具有令人难以置信的象征意义，因为当然，纽伦堡是集会的中心。它被纳粹奉为种族纯洁的德国应有的一切的化身。所以让犹太教堂站在那里，那是一个巨大的结构，有一个巨大的圆顶，非常违背老城的中世纪建筑。对纳粹来说，这是一种持续的侮辱。但同时，对于任何关注历史的人来说，不仅是最近的反犹太主义，而且是追溯到中世纪的反犹太主义，那座犹太教堂的毁灭是一个可怕的象征性时刻，因为之前已经有两座犹太教堂了。两座都在反犹太大屠杀中被摧毁，第一座是在1349年。所以在黑死病的背景下，那种瘟疫的感觉再次出现，反犹太主义被某种程度上
interfused but it's also tragic because that synagogue had served as a symbol of the integration of German Jews into the fatherland because the foundation stone leaders of the various Christian denominations in Nuremberg had come to that ceremony and the Kaiser had come and had been shown around it by the chief rabbi there. Symbolically, from the Nazi point of view, it's a triumphant moment. From anyone who had valued the Jewish contribution to Germany, it's a terrible moment. Yeah. It's interesting that you say the terrible symbolism, because I think there's a real sense that this is the moment when if you had any remaining illusions about what Nazis intend and about the depths of their hatred this is the moment at which those are blown away so it's that summer 1938 that it is made compulsory
融合在一起，但这也很悲惨，因为那座犹太教堂曾作为德国犹太人融入祖国的象征，因为纽伦堡各基督教教派的领导人都参加了奠基仪式，皇帝也来了，并由首席拉比带他参观。从纳粹的角度来看，这在象征意义上是一个胜利的时刻。对于任何重视犹太人对德国贡献的人来说，这是一个可怕的时刻。是的。你说那种可怕的象征意义很有趣，因为我认为确实有一种感觉，这是那一刻，如果你对纳粹的意图和他们仇恨的深度还有任何残留的幻想，这一刻它们都被吹走了。所以是1938年那个夏天，它成为强制性的，
for German Jews if they don't have Jewish names they have to adopt the forename Israel or Sarah to show that they're Jewish and they have a J stamped in their passports. It's also at that moment that the Nazis launch their final drive to basically push Jews out of German economic life, to take over, to steal Jewish businesses. And actually the terrible thing about this, we've talked a bit about how areas of society are complicit. So the way that they would do this is they will hit you with tax bills. They will hit you with fines. They will intimidate you. They will basically put every possible bit of pressure on you to give up your business. To sell up and get out.
对于德国犹太人来说，如果他们没有犹太名字，他们必须采用“以色列”或“萨拉”作为名字，以表明他们是犹太人，并且他们的护照上盖有“J”字样。也正是在那一刻，纳粹发起了最后的行动，基本上将犹太人赶出德国的经济生活，接管、窃取犹太企业。实际上，关于这一点最可怕的事情是，我们谈论了一些社会领域是如何同流合污的。所以他们这样做的方式是，他们会用税单打击你。他们会用罚款打击你。他们会恐吓你。他们基本上会给你施加一切可能的压力，让你放弃你的生意。卖掉它，然后离开。
To get out, exactly. And the people who collaborate in this, the people who gain from it, are all the big names of the German economy. So anyone who follows football will know that Bayern Munich's stadium is called the Allianz Arena, the stadium in Munich. Allianz is one of the companies that benefits from this, that takes over Jewish businesses. But Allianz are not alone. I'm not singling them out out of some prejudice or whatever. Krupp, Tyson, Flick, IG Farben, the Deutsche Bank, the Dresdner Bank. These are the big names
离开，完全正确。而那些在其中合作的人，那些从中获利的人，都是德国经济界的大人物。所以任何关注足球的人都会知道，拜仁慕尼黑的体育场被称为安联竞技场，慕尼黑的体育场。安联是受益于此的公司之一，它接管了犹太企业。但安联并不是唯一一家。我并不是因为某种偏见而单独挑出他们。克虏伯、蒂森、弗利克、法本公司、德意志银行、德累斯顿银行。这些都是大名字，
of German economic life. And they all gain from taking over their Jewish rivals, taking over Jewish property, premises, you know, hoovering up bits of their markets, all of that kind of thing. And presumably leading Nazis as well are benefiting. Of course. So we've talked about how Goering loves a bit of plunder.
德国经济生活中的大名字。他们都从接管他们的犹太竞争对手、接管犹太财产、房产、你知道，吞噬他们市场份额的碎片中获利，所有这些事情。而且大概纳粹高层也从中受益。当然。所以我们谈到了戈林是如何喜欢掠夺的。
A fur coat. Yeah, exactly. Nazis are prospering, but you don't have to be a Nazi to do it. But you remember the episode that we did on Unity Mitford, where Hitler gives her a flat and she goes around Munich and she has a choice of three flats. And she ends up in one of them and says, oh, I'll have this and goes around saying, oh, I'll get rid of these curtains. We'll have new chairs here. While the former owners of the flat are sobbing in the hall, surrounded by the few fragments that they've been allowed. I mean, it's a terrible process. But you could see that, Tom, as a metaphor for what happens generally in the German economy. So the people who benefit from basically the expulsion of the Jews from the mainstream of German life, they're not just Goering and other corrupt Nazi functionaries. They are doctors and lawyers, people who think, brilliant,
一件皮草大衣。是的，完全正确。纳粹正在繁荣，但你不必是纳粹也能做到这一点。但你还记得我们做的关于尤妮蒂·米特福德（Unity Mitford）的那一集吗？希特勒给了她一套公寓，她在慕尼黑四处走动，她有三套公寓可以选择。她最终住进了其中一套，并说，哦，我要这个，然后四处说，哦，我要把这些窗帘扔掉。我们要在这里放新椅子。而公寓的前主人在走廊里啜泣，被允许带走的只有少数碎片。我的意思是，这是一个可怕的过程。但你可以把这看作是德国经济中普遍发生的事情的隐喻。所以那些基本上从犹太人被驱逐出德国主流生活而受益的人，他们不仅仅是戈林和其他腐败的纳粹官员。他们是医生和律师，那些认为“太棒了，
my Jewish competitors are out of the way. I can take their customers, all good for me. You know, university professors and academics start tailoring their research to the demands of the Nazi regime. So, for example, if you're an academic, you might turn your hand to studies showing how you can measure a Jewish skull or a history showing how the Jews have always betrayed Germany or whatever it might be. Think of Carl Schmitt. The jurist, yeah. Who, even well before this, had been proposing that any book by any Jewish scholar should be put into its own category. There should be a kind of Jewish section in every library, you know, quarantined. So it's not as though this is being forced on German academics. I mean, they are enthusiastic collaborators in it.
我的犹太竞争对手被清除了。我可以抢走他们的客户，对我来说都很好。”你知道，大学教授和学者开始根据纳粹政权的要求调整他们的研究。例如，如果你是一名学者，你可能会转而研究如何测量犹太人的头骨，或者写一段历史，展示犹太人是如何一直背叛德国的，或者无论它可能是什么。想想卡尔·施米特（Carl Schmitt）。那位法学家，是的。甚至在此之前很久，他就提出任何犹太学者的任何书都应该被归入自己的类别。每家图书馆都应该有一个犹太部分，你知道，被隔离。所以这并不是说这是强加给德国学者的。我的意思是，他们是热情的合作者。
And I think by 1938, by the summer of 1938, so many different branches of kind of civil society, judges, lawyers, policemen, just people who run things or indeed, you know, shopkeepers who've seen their rivals eliminated. All of these people
我认为到1938年，到1938年夏天，公民社会的许多不同分支，法官、律师、警察，只是那些经营事情的人，或者确实，你知道，看到竞争对手被消灭的店主。所有这些人
are complicit now. They're in on it. Yeah. Once you are in on it, there's no going back as it were because you don't want to admit that you were wrong or that the process
现在都是同谋了。他们参与其中了。是的。一旦你参与其中，就没有回头路了，因为你不想承认你错了，或者这个过程
was wrong to begin with. So that ratcheting up has really had an effect on lots of different areas of society. And it's been directed from the Fuhrer. He has set the tone, but then people on the ground have kind of responded to it. So it's not just, this is a top-down totalitarian system. That's not how the Nazi dictatorship works. No, because, I mean, this is the whole point of Hitler comparing himself to Pericles, who is famous as the great democratic leader of Athens. But Pericles is the embodiment of the will to power as the Nazis see it. And Hitler is the same, that what is happening is cast as an expression of a primordial racial impulse. And that Hitler
从一开始就是错的。所以这种加剧确实对社会的许多不同领域产生了影响。而且它是由元首指导的。他定下了基调，但随后地面上的人们以某种方式做出了回应。所以这不仅仅是，这是一个自上而下的极权主义系统。纳粹独裁统治不是这样运作的。不，因为，我的意思是，这就是希特勒将自己与伯里克利（Pericles）进行比较的全部意义所在，伯里克利作为雅典伟大的民主领袖而闻名。但伯里克利是纳粹所看到的权力意志的化身。希特勒也是一样，正在发生的事情被描绘成一种原始种族冲动的表达。而希特勒
is merely the standard bearer for this and that the German people are being awakened to this racial heritage and this explains what is now happening. It's a measure of the Nazi achievement that they have encouraged this. Yes. Now that violence is always still there
仅仅是这一点的旗手，德国人民正在被唤醒以认识到这种种族遗产，这解释了现在正在发生的事情。这是纳粹成就的一个衡量标准。是的。现在那种暴力仍然一直存在，
and it's actually got worse in the summer of 1938. So there are attacks on Jewish homes. There are attacks on the remaining doctor surgeries or law firms or shops or whatever. And that really reaches a peak in about June or July 1938. So there's a real, what Richard Evans describes as a pogrom-like atmosphere. There's a sense that something is brewing. Of course, the question is, you know, all this business that they've been saying, this rhetorical stuff about removing Jews from Germany or indeed from Europe, how are they going to do that? You know, will intimidating people into fleeing the Reich be enough?
而且在1938年夏天实际上变得更糟了。所以有针对犹太家庭的袭击。有针对剩下的医生诊所、律师事务所、商店或任何东西的袭击。这在1938年6月或7月左右真正达到了顶峰。所以有一种真正的，理查德·埃文斯所描述的“大屠杀般的氛围”。有一种感觉，有什么事情正在酝酿。当然，问题是，你知道，他们一直在说的所有这些事情，关于将犹太人从德国甚至从欧洲移除的修辞，他们将如何做到这一点？你知道，恐吓人们逃离帝国就足够了吗？
And at this point, they are contemplating lots of different schemes. So one of them, very famously, is about reaching some sort of deal with a foreign country, a foreign land, which will take the entire Jewish population of Germany. So not Rwanda, but Madagascar. Madagascar, exactly. So Goebbels makes a note, the Führer wants to push them all out, negotiate with Poland or Romania, Madagascar would be most suitable. So this is an idea that runs right through the 1930s. It's incredibly sort of implausible, sort of fanciful idea, but that's one notion. Palestine, which we mentioned last time, is another idea.
在这一点上，他们正在考虑许多不同的计划。所以其中一个，非常著名的是关于与一个外国、一个外国达成某种协议，该国将接收德国的全部犹太人口。所以不是卢旺达，而是马达加斯加。马达加斯加，完全正确。所以戈培尔做了一个记录，元首想把他们全部赶走，与波兰或罗马尼亚谈判，马达加斯加是最合适的。所以这是一个贯穿整个1930年代的想法。这是一种极其不可信的、异想天开的想法，但这是一种概念。巴勒斯坦，我们上次提到的，是另一个想法。
So there's a guy called Leopold von Mildenstein, who's an SS man. He goes to Palestine and he has meetings with Zionists. He's the guy who was Eichmann's boss. Yeah. Kind of leading that whole drive. Exactly. Yes, he was. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah.
所以有一个叫利奥波德·冯·米尔登斯坦（Leopold von Mildenstein）的人，他是一个党卫军成员。他去了巴勒斯坦，并与犹太复国主义者举行了会议。他就是艾希曼的老板。是的。某种程度上领导了整个行动。完全正确。是的，他是。完全正确。是的。是的。
But actually, a lot of Nazis don't quite like that idea because they think if we establish a Jewish homeland in Palestine, well, we're just storing up trouble for ourselves later on. Potential threat. I mean, one day that will be the base for an enemy empire that will want to fight us. So obviously that's not a good idea. Now there's another idea, which is we just basically find some kind of barren wasteland. You know, who knows? Maybe when we've conquered the Soviet Union, we put them all in Siberia or whatever. Because that's the theme of Michael Chabon's great novel,
但实际上，很多纳粹并不太喜欢那个想法，因为他们认为如果我们建立一个犹太家园在巴勒斯坦，嗯，我们只是在为自己以后储存麻烦。潜在的威胁。我的意思是，有一天那将成为一个想要与我们作战的敌对帝国的基地。所以显然那不是一个好主意。现在有另一个想法，就是我们基本上找到某种荒凉的荒地。你知道，谁知道呢？也许当我们征服了苏联，我们把他们都放在西伯利亚或什么地方。因为那是迈克尔·查邦（Michael Chabon）伟大的小说《犹太警察工会》的主题，
The Yiddish Policeman's Union, isn't it? Where they all end up in Canada. It's kind of alternative history where Jews haven't gone to Palestine. They've gone to the frozen wastes of the American North. Yeah, absolutely. And I think that idea about the frozen waste is really important because it reminds us this is always latently genocidal. The idea is not, let's find them a place to live where they can just crack on and we can forget about them. It is, let us find a place to live where they can just crack on and, you know, we can forget about them. It is, let us find a place to put them where they will die. And that is why one thing that we haven't mentioned, but which of course, certainly people in Britain will know, is that it's very difficult. I mean, the reason that the Nazis are having all these arguments is because Jews cannot emigrate easily to countries like Britain, to France, to America, because there are limits put up there. But also,
不是吗？他们最终都去了加拿大。这是一种替代历史，犹太人没有去巴勒斯坦。他们去了美国北部的冰冻荒原。是的，绝对。而且我认为关于冰冻荒原的想法真的很重要，因为它提醒我们这总是潜在的种族灭绝。这个想法不是，让我们为他们找一个可以生活的地方，让他们可以继续生活，我们可以忘记他们。它是，让我们找一个地方把他们放进去，让他们死去。这就是为什么我们没有提到的一件事，但当然，英国的人肯定会知道，那就是这非常困难。我的意思是，纳粹进行所有这些争论的原因是因为犹太人不能轻易移民到英国、法国、美国这样的国家，因为那里有设置的限制。但也，
presumably, they don't want to let them go to prosperous and successful economies, because there the threat will be even more paramount. Yes, exactly. I mean, don't forget, they're saying again and again, they must be removed from Europe. Goebbels says that. So in other words, if they all go to live in the Netherlands or in France or in London, that is sub-ideal from the Nazi point of view because the terrible apocalyptic threat is still there. People have these great arguments about where the Holocaust originated, when was the order given for the final solution or this sort of thing. To my mind, there is clearly a genocidal impulse, if only rhetorically, there all through the 1930s, and it has become more and more pronounced. I mean, we introduced the previous episode with Hitler talking about rotting corpses of Jews hanging from the gallows in Munich. So, I mean, it's been there from the beginning, right? Yeah, absolutely it has. So let me just end this half of the episode with an
大概，他们不想让他们去繁荣和成功的经济体，因为那里的威胁会更加突出。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，别忘了，他们一次又一次地说，他们必须被从欧洲移除。戈培尔这么说。所以换句话说，如果他们都去住在荷兰、法国或伦敦，从纳粹的角度来看，这是次优的，因为可怕的世界末日威胁仍然存在。人们对大屠杀起源于哪里、最终解决方案的命令是什么时候下达的或这类事情有很大的争论。在我看来，显然存在一种种族灭绝的冲动，即使只是在修辞上，在整个1930年代一直存在，而且它变得越来越明显。我的意思是，我们在上一集开头介绍了希特勒谈论挂在慕尼黑绞刑架上的犹太人腐烂的尸体。所以，我的意思是，它从一开始就在那里，对吧？是的，绝对是。所以让我用一个例子来结束这一半的剧集，
example of how this might affect one particular Jewish family. We'll pick a family called the Grinspans. So they are Jews originally from Poland. They'd come to Germany in 1911 and settled in Hanover and opened a tailor shop, Zindel and Rivka Grinspan. They are Yiddish speaking, what are called Ostjuden, so Jews from the East. And they have a son born in 1921 called Herschel. He's a bright boy, but very sensitive. He feels his Jewishness very keen keenly he's bullied at school because he's jewish he wants to emigrate to palestine so he does want to join the zionists but he's told he's too young so he's sent off to live with an uncle and aunt in paris so from the nazi perspective they're pleased he's gone but
关于这可能如何影响一个特定的犹太家庭。我们选一个叫格林斯潘（Grinspan）的家庭。所以他们是最初来自波兰的犹太人。他们于1911年来到德国，定居在汉诺威，开了一家裁缝店，津德尔（Zindel）和里夫卡·格林斯潘（Rivka Grinspan）。他们是讲意第绪语的，所谓的“东方犹太人”（Ostjuden），即来自东方的犹太人。他们有一个1921年出生的儿子叫赫歇尔（Herschel）。他是一个聪明的男孩，但非常敏感。他非常敏锐地感受到了自己的犹太身份，他在学校因为是犹太人而被欺负，他想移民到巴勒斯坦，所以他确实想加入犹太复国主义者，但他被告知他太小了，所以他被送去和巴黎的叔叔阿姨住在一起。所以从纳粹的角度来看，他们很高兴他走了，但
this is a sub-ideal solution. In Paris, he lives with other Polish Orthodox Jews. He doesn't really mix much. He doesn't learn French. He speaks Yiddish. And he reads at the end of 1938 that in Poland, the authorities there responding to anti-Semitic pressure want to strip Polish Jews living abroad of their Polish citizenship. And in response, so this is interesting, it's the Nazis responding to another Central European state. In response, the Gestapo have decided to arrest all Polish Jews in Germany and to deport them. And his parents are among those people who have been arrested and stripped of their property and put onto a train bound for Poland.
这是一个次优的解决方案。在巴黎，他和其他波兰正统犹太人住在一起。他并没有真正融入太多。他没有学法语。他讲意第绪语。他在1938年底读到，在波兰，那里的当局响应反犹太压力，想要剥夺居住在国外的波兰犹太人的波兰公民身份。作为回应，所以这很有趣，这是纳粹对另一个中欧国家的回应。作为回应，盖世太保决定逮捕德国所有的波兰犹太人并将他们驱逐出境。他的父母就在那些被逮捕、被剥夺财产并被送上一列开往波兰的火车的人之中。
So Herschel, Grinschmann, he hears this and he is understandably absolutely horrified. And he decides he's going to do something about it. And on the 7th of November 1938, he wakes up at his home in Paris. He goes out. He goes to a shop and buys a revolver. And on the 7th of November, 1938, he wakes up at his home in Paris. He goes out, he goes to a shop and buys a revolver. And then he walks to Rue de Lille, where the German embassy is based. And he goes in, and as he goes in, he actually walks past the ambassador. He doesn't realize he's walked past the ambassador.
所以赫歇尔·格林斯潘，他听到了这个消息，他理所当然地感到非常震惊。他决定他要为此做点什么。1938年11月7日，他在巴黎的家中醒来。他出去了。他去了一家商店买了一把左轮手枪。1938年11月7日，他在巴黎的家中醒来。他出去了，他去了一家商店买了一把左轮手枪。然后他走到德国大使馆所在的里尔街（Rue de Lille）。他进去了，当他进去时，他实际上走过了大使。他没有意识到他走过了大使。
And he goes to the desk and he says, I need to see somebody senior. I've got secret intelligence. I've got really important documents. I need to see somebody. And the clerk says, well, you can go and talk to this guy. And he basically picks the single most junior person at the embassy, who's a guy in his late twenties called Ernst von Rath. And Herschel Grinspan goes into von Rath's office and sort of sits down or whatever. And Rath says, well, what's this intelligence? And at that point, Grinchman pulls out his revolver and he shoots Rath five times in the chest. And in his pocket, Grinchman is carrying a note. He says, I'm doing this to avenge my parents' tragedy and that of 12,000
他走到柜台前说，我需要见一位高级官员。我有秘密情报。我有非常重要的文件。我需要见某人。职员说，好吧，你可以去和这个人谈谈。他基本上挑选了大使馆里级别最低的人，一个二十多岁叫恩斯特·冯·拉特（Ernst von Rath）的人。赫歇尔·格林斯潘走进冯·拉特的办公室，坐下来或什么的。拉特说，好吧，这是什么情报？就在那时，格林斯潘掏出他的左轮手枪，他向拉特胸部开了五枪。在他的口袋里，格林斯潘带着一张纸条。他说，我这样做是为了报复我父母的悲剧和12,000名
Jews who are being kicked out of Germany. I want to make sure that the whole world hears my protest. Please forgive me." It's a note to his parents. And that, Tom, is the moment that launches the most savage and shocking of all the Nazi attacks on the Jews thus far, the Night of Broken Glass. Okay, thank you, Dominic. We will talk about the consequences of that, what happens in the second half. See you then. I'm Marina Hyde.
正在被赶出德国的犹太人的悲剧。我想确保全世界都听到我的抗议。请原谅我。”这是一张给父母的纸条。汤姆，那一刻引发了迄今为止纳粹对犹太人最野蛮、最令人震惊的袭击，“水晶之夜”。好的，谢谢你，多米尼克。我们将讨论其后果，下半部分会发生什么。到时候见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. Dominic, in the first half, we ended with the shooting of Ernst von Rath, a junior official in the German embassy in Paris by a Polish Jew outraged by the wanted the whole world to hear his protest. And of course, the whole world does hear his protest, but particularly one place where his protest is heard is in Germany. Yeah. So von Braat, the guy who he shot, the young diplomat, he died two days later on the afternoon of the 9th of November. And as ill luck would have it, it's the 15th anniversary of the Beer Hall Putsch of 1923. But the echo here is of the Reichstag fire, isn't it? Which likewise was a wholly unexpected action by an enemy of the Nazis that played into their hands. Yeah, exactly. I think the parallels are uncanny, really. And the fact that it happens, it happens on the 15th anniversary of the Beer Hall Putsch. So all the Nazi old
你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。多米尼克，在上半部分，我们以波兰犹太人枪杀德国驻巴黎大使馆初级官员恩斯特·冯·拉特结束，他因为想要全世界听到他的抗议而感到愤怒。当然，全世界确实听到了他的抗议，但特别有一个地方听到了他的抗议，那就是德国。是的。所以冯·拉特，那个被他枪杀的年轻外交官，两天后，即11月9日下午去世了。而不幸的是，那是1923年啤酒馆政变15周年纪念日。但这里的回声是国会纵火案，不是吗？同样是纳粹敌人完全意想不到的行动，却落入了他们的手中。是的，完全正确。我认为这种相似之处真的很不可思议。而且它发生的事实，它发生在啤酒馆政变15周年纪念日。所以所有的纳粹老
fighters, as they're called, are meeting in Munich. They're gathered together and they hear the news of this assassination in Paris. And as with the Reichstag fire, exactly that, one of Hitler's enemies has handed him a chance to seize an opportunity. And this is what happens. So on the 8th of November, the day after the shooting, the German press is full of, the anti-Semitic abuse has been turned up to 11. And there are demonstrations breaking out. There are violent pogroms. The tension is really at sort of the highest possible level. Now, the news of von Raat's death comes through publicly on the evening of the next day, the 9th.
战士，正如他们所称的那样，都在慕尼黑开会。他们聚集在一起，听到了巴黎这次暗杀的消息。正如国会纵火案一样，完全是这样，希特勒的敌人之一给了他一个抓住机会的机会。这就是发生的事情。所以11月8日，枪击事件发生的第二天，德国媒体充斥着，反犹太主义的谩骂被调到了11级。示威活动爆发了。发生了暴力大屠杀。紧张局势确实处于尽可能高的水平。现在，冯·拉特死亡的消息在第二天，即9日晚上公开传出。
And Hitler's probably heard about it in the afternoon because he'd sent his own doctor to von Raat's bedside. All the Nazi top brass are meeting at the old town hall in Munich. They have a big dinner and at that dinner there is a very public scene where a messenger comes in to tell
希特勒可能在下午就听说了，因为他派了自己的医生去冯·拉特的床边。所有的纳粹高层都在慕尼黑的老市政厅开会。他们吃了一顿大餐，在那顿晚餐上，有一个非常公开的场景，一名信使进来告诉
Hitler and Goebbels that von Rath has died, that he's succumbed to his injuries. So the theatre of it. Yeah, they probably knew it already. They almost certainly
希特勒和戈培尔，冯·拉特已经去世了，他没能从伤势中挺过来。所以这是一种戏剧性。是的，他们可能已经知道了。他们几乎肯定
knew it already. But they almost staged this theatrical reenactment of hearing the news so everybody can see it. it. And then they kind of huddle together in a very excited histrionic manner, again, publicly for everybody to see. Looking very serious. And then Hitler sort of rushes off to his Munich apartment. So what are they talking about? Well, almost certainly what happens in that conversation is Hitler says to Goebbels, this is the chance to move definitively against the Jews of Germany. What we will do is we will launch physical attacks on Jewish families. We will round up as many Jewish men as possible. I mean, they're talking about tens of thousands of people and throw them into prison. And this is our chance to intimidate as many Jews as we can to get out of Germany. This is the chance
已经知道了。但他们几乎上演了这种听到消息的戏剧性重演，以便每个人都能看到。然后他们以一种非常兴奋、做作的方式挤在一起，再次，公开地让每个人都看到。看起来非常严肃。然后希特勒匆匆赶往他在慕尼黑的公寓。那么他们在谈论什么呢？嗯，几乎可以肯定在那次谈话中发生的事情是希特勒对戈培尔说，这是最终对德国犹太人采取行动的机会。我们将要做的是，我们将对犹太家庭发动身体攻击。我们将尽可能多地围捕犹太男子。我的意思是，他们在谈论成千上万的人，并把他们扔进监狱。这是我们恐吓尽可能多的犹太人离开德国的机会。这是机会
to purge Germany of its Jewish population. And the way they're going to spin it is they will present it to the world as a spontaneous, improvised, you know, expression of German anger. Exactly. But it's actually going to be directed from the top. So Goebbels is the person who really is in charge of directing it. He gives a speech an hour later at 10 o'clock in which he addresses the assembled crowd. He says to them, it's a terrible thing that von Raad is dead. Already people across the Reich are expressing their anger and attacking Jews.
清除德国的犹太人口。他们将要采取的方式是，他们将向世界展示这是一种自发的、即兴的、你知道，德国愤怒的表达。完全正确。但它实际上将由最高层指导。所以戈培尔是真正负责指导它的人。一小时后，在10点钟，他发表了演讲，向聚集的人群发表讲话。他对他们说，冯·拉特死了是一件可怕的事情。整个帝国的人们已经在表达他们的愤怒并攻击犹太人。
Quite right too. You know, everybody should take inspiration from this. Let's all do it. Now, the orders are going out late that night across Germany, and they are very explicit. It must be focused. It must appear to be spontaneous. It shouldn't be hooliganism and sort of massive looting and chaos and stuff although in reality it does turn out to be very chaotic and we mustn't touch foreign jews or foreigners because you know that
说得太对了。你知道，每个人都应该从中获得灵感。让我们都这样做。现在，命令在那天深夜传遍了德国，而且非常明确。它必须是有针对性的。它必须看起来是自发的。它不应该是流氓行为和某种大规模的抢劫和混乱之类的，尽管实际上它确实变得非常混乱，而且我们绝不能触碰外国犹太人或外国人，因为你知道那
will inflame opinion overseas and crucially it must be carried out in civilian dress in other words it must not look like this is being done by the ss or the brown shirts yeah it must look like this is the german people so himmler that night sends a message to the ss and he says if you're going to do it if you're going to join in you must dress in civilian clothes you must not dress in uss uniforms hydrick his deputy now of course as you said earlier the ss are running the police the ss are basically in charge of the Gestapo and so on. So they tell them, you must not intervene. You must not protect Jewish families. You must not stop the destruction of synagogues and Jewish cemeteries.
会激怒海外舆论，而且至关重要的是，它必须穿着平民服装进行，换句话说，它看起来绝不能像是党卫军或褐衫军所为。是的，它必须看起来像是德国人民所为。所以希姆莱那天晚上给党卫军发了一条信息，他说如果你要这样做，如果你要加入，你必须穿平民服装，你绝不能穿党卫军制服。海德里希，他的副手，现在当然，正如你之前所说，党卫军在管理警察，党卫军基本上负责盖世太保等等。所以他们告诉他们，你们绝不能干预。你们绝不能保护犹太家庭。你们绝不能阻止犹太教堂和犹太墓地的破坏。
And you must make preparations to arrest as many people as possible. The head of the Gestapo, Heinrich Muller, he sends out an instruction. He says, tell the jails in Germany to prepare for the reception of 30,000 Jews, and especially let's choose properted Jews, i.e. people with money, because then we can take their money. We want their money. We want their possessions. We want everything. powers across the Reich, this gigantic pogrom, a nationwide pogrom in cities and towns and villages. I'll just give you a couple of examples. I mean, there's so many terrible examples. These are both from Richard Evans' book on the Third Reich in Power. He points to a town in Franconia,
而且你们必须做好准备，尽可能多地逮捕人。盖世太保首脑海因里希·穆勒（Heinrich Muller），他发出了指示。他说，告诉德国的监狱准备接收30,000名犹太人，特别是让我们选择有财产的犹太人，即有钱的人，因为那样我们就可以拿走他们的钱。我们想要他们的钱。我们想要他们的财产。我们想要一切。在整个帝国，这场巨大的大屠杀，在城市、城镇和村庄进行全国性的大屠杀。我只给你举几个例子。我的意思是，有太多可怕的例子。这些都来自理查德·埃文斯关于第三帝国权力的书。他指出了弗兰肯地区的一个小镇，
always very anti-Semitic Franconia, called Treutlingen. The local stormtrooper commander gets an instruction just after midnight, gets a phone call, round up all your guys. He rounds them all up. They rampage through this little town. They smash all the shops. They burn down the synagogue. Local people start to gather, not to stop them, but to encourage them, to cheer them on, to help them smash windows of shops and start looting the shops. They burst into the homes of local people. There's a guy called Moritz Meyer, who later writes an account of what happens. He wakes up and he realises that a stormtrooper's in his house downstairs. His family are asleep and they're smashing all his furniture and all
总是非常反犹太的弗兰肯，叫特罗伊特林根（Treutlingen）。当地的冲锋队指挥官在午夜后接到一个指示，接到一个电话，把你们的人都召集起来。他把他们都召集起来。他们在那个小镇上横冲直撞。他们砸碎了所有的商店。他们烧毁了犹太教堂。当地人开始聚集，不是为了阻止他们，而是为了鼓励他们，为他们加油，帮助他们砸碎商店的窗户并开始抢劫商店。他们闯入当地人的家中。有一个叫莫里茨·迈耶（Moritz Meyer）的人，他后来写了一份关于发生的事情的记录。他醒来，意识到一个冲锋队员在他楼下的房子里。他的家人在睡觉，他们正在砸碎他所有的家具和所有
his crockery and whatnot. They force his family down into the cellar. Then they force the family to smash all their own wine bottles in the cellar and all this kind of thing. And then at the end, Meyer himself, they try to get out to the railway station. He ends up being arrested. And this sort of scene is repeated in towns all across Germany. The other example I was going to pick from Richard Evans' book, it's just a tiny thing, but it's really heartbreaking. In a place called Esslingen in Baden-Württemberg, which is near Stuttgart, there was a Jewish orphanage and people break into the orphanage
他的陶器之类的东西。他们强迫他的家人下到地窖里。然后他们强迫家人砸碎地窖里他们自己所有的酒瓶和所有这类事情。最后，迈耶本人，他们试图去火车站。他最终被捕了。这种场景在德国各地的城镇中重复上演。我打算从理查德·埃文斯的书中选的另一个例子，这只是一件小事，但真的很令人心碎。在巴登-符腾堡州一个叫埃斯林根（Esslingen）的地方，靠近斯图加特，有一所犹太孤儿院，人们闯入孤儿院
with axes and sledgehammers. They destroy everything, the kids' books or their religious stuff, anything they can find, toys. Yeah, they burn them all. And then they say to the children,
用斧头和大锤。他们摧毁了一切，孩子们的书或他们的宗教物品，任何他们能找到的东西，玩具。是的，他们把它们全烧了。然后他们对孩子们说，
if you do not leave, we will burn you too. So you have these poor kids straggling along the roads in the dark, walking for hours in tears, and they have to basically walk all the way to Stuttgart, which I think is about three hours away, before they can find anyone to shelter them or anything like that. I mean, that's just one scene among thousands upon thousands. As all the reports of this flood in, Goebbels and Hitler are delighted. I mean, Goebbels writes in his diary, the people's anger is raging. Nothing can
如果你不离开，我们也会烧死你们。所以这些可怜的孩子在黑暗中沿着道路蹒跚而行，哭着走了几个小时，他们基本上不得不一路走到斯图加特，我想大约有三个小时的路程，然后才能找到人来庇护他们或类似的事情。我的意思是，这只是成千上万个场景中的一个。随着所有关于此的报道涌入，戈培尔和希特勒很高兴。我的意思是，戈培尔在日记中写道，人民的愤怒正在肆虐。没有什么能
be done against it. And I don't want to do anything either. Should be given free reign. As I drive back to my hotel, the windows shatter. Bravo, bravo. The synagogues are burning in all the big cities. You know, the delight, the glee. You talked before about the kind of, the way that the Nazis rationalise and they intellectualise what they're doing. But there is a kind of savagery. Yeah, of course, a relish. You know, that sadistic joy and destruction
必须采取行动。我也不想袖手旁观。应该让他们放手去做。当我开车回酒店时，窗户碎了。好极了，好极了。犹太教堂在各大城市燃烧。你知道，那种喜悦，那种狂欢。你之前谈到纳粹合理化和知识化他们所作所为的方式。但确实有一种野蛮。是的，当然，一种享受。你知道，那种施虐的快乐和破坏
which we shouldn't lose sight of. But, Dominic, this whole thing has been set up as being a spontaneous expression of public will. So what is the kind of official position of the Nazi hierarchy and what's happening? They absolutely back it. They say it's a completely reasonable expression of the utterly justifiable anger of the German people who have been victimized and brutalized by a worldwide jury for too long. However, they don't want the disorder to get completely out of control. So the following lunchtime, Goebbels goes to the Osteria in Munich, which of course is Hitler's
我们不应该忽视这一点。但是，多米尼克，整件事被设定为公众意志的自发表达。那么纳粹高层对正在发生的事情的官方立场是什么？他们绝对支持。他们说这是德国人民完全合理的表达，他们长期以来一直受到全世界犹太人的迫害和残暴对待。然而，他们不想让混乱完全失控。所以第二天午餐时间，戈培尔去了慕尼黑的Osteria餐厅，那当然是希特勒的
favorite restaurant. It's the restaurant, Tom, I'll mention it before you do, that Unity Mitford used to hang out at in a hope of catching Hitler's eye. There, Hitler issues an order, end of the action, stop. And of course, the terrible thing is that, I mean, that's one of many terrible things, is it doesn't stop, that it actually continues, that now so many people have a taste for the sadism and the cruelty. So again, the examples of the next couple of days, Jews are forced to sing religious songs in the street, they're drenched in water, they're kicked and they're made to dance outside the synagogue in essen jewish men are rounded up and their beards are set on fire in a place called meppen they're made to lie down outside the storm
最喜欢的餐厅。汤姆，我会在你提到之前先说，那是尤妮蒂·米特福德过去常去的地方，希望能引起希特勒的注意。在那里，希特勒下达了命令，行动结束，停止。当然，可怕的事情是，我的意思是，这是许多可怕事情中的一件，它并没有停止，它实际上还在继续，现在这么多人对施虐和残忍产生了兴趣。所以再次重申，接下来几天的例子，犹太人被迫在街上唱宗教歌曲，他们被浇上水，被踢打，被迫在埃森的犹太教堂外跳舞，犹太男子被围捕，胡子被点燃，在一个叫梅彭的地方，他们被迫躺在冲锋队
trooper headquarters the sa headquarters and then the brown shirts literally walk over the top of them the really shocking thing actually is and we've mentioned this so many times in this series, I still find it, you know, it's sort of haunting and terrifying how much children and young people are involved in these events. So in Frankfurt, for example, kids are taken out of school to spit at the Jews who have been rounded up. But it's not surprising, is it? I mean, if they've been indoctrinated in this, that's what they're going to do. No, I guess it's not surprising, Tom. No, it's not surprising, is it? I mean, if they've been indoctrinated in this, that's what they're going to do. No, I guess it's not surprising, Tom. No, it's not surprising at all. The morality they've been taught is a Nazi morality.
总部，冲锋队总部外面，然后褐衫军真的从他们身上踩了过去。真正令人震惊的是，我们在本系列中多次提到这一点，我仍然觉得，你知道，这有点令人难以忘怀和恐惧，孩子们和年轻人参与这些事件的程度。例如，在法兰克福，孩子们被带出学校去向被围捕的犹太人吐口水。但这并不令人惊讶，不是吗？我的意思是，如果他们被灌输了这些思想，他们就会这样做。不，我想这并不令人惊讶，汤姆。不，这并不令人惊讶，不是吗？我的意思是，如果他们被灌输了这些思想，他们就会这样做。不，我想这并不令人惊讶，汤姆。不，一点也不令人惊讶。他们被教导的道德观是纳粹道德观。
Yeah. Where what they're doing is the right thing. It's a good thing. It's moral. It's for the good of the race. But it's nonetheless horrifying though, right? Of course. Of course. I mean, in the Tsar land, there are stories about Jewish people trying to escape and mobs of small children running after them, kicking them, throwing stones at them, hitting them with sticks, you know, making them fall to the ground and then hitting them and all this sort of thing. I mean, it's kind of diabolical. So enormous amounts of damage, you know, hundreds of millions of marks worth of damage when they finally clear up all the broken glass.
是的。他们所做的是正确的事情。这是一件好事。这是道德的。这是为了种族的利益。但尽管如此，这还是很可怕，对吧？当然。当然。我的意思是，在萨尔地区，有关于犹太人试图逃跑的故事，成群的小孩追着他们，踢他们，向他们扔石头，用棍子打他们，你知道，让他们摔倒在地，然后打他们，诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，这简直是恶魔般的。所以造成了巨大的破坏，你知道，当他们最终清理完所有碎玻璃时，损失了数亿马克。
And that's where the name Kristallnacht comes from. The Reichskristallnacht, yeah. The Knights of Broken Glass. Yeah. How many people died? Some estimates as low as a couple of hundred, some into the early thousands, kind of one, two, three thousand. As in Vienna, we talked about this in the Anschluss episode, some people kill themselves.
这就是“水晶之夜”这个名字的由来。帝国水晶之夜，是的。碎玻璃之夜。是的。有多少人死了？一些估计低至几百人，一些达到几千人，大约一、二、三千人。正如在维也纳，我们在德奥合并那一集谈到过，有些人自杀了。
About 30,000 people ended up being arrested and imprisoned in concentration camps. Are there rapes? Do you know? I don't know, Tom. Because that would be illegal, presumably. It would be against the law. Yeah, that's an interesting question. Is there any hint of sexual violence? I haven't seen any in the history books that I've read. So probably not.
大约有3万人最终被捕并关进集中营。有强奸事件吗？你知道吗？我不知道，汤姆。因为那大概是非法的。那将是违法的。是的，这是一个有趣的问题。有任何性暴力的迹象吗？我在读过的历史书中没有看到任何相关记载。所以可能没有。
Perhaps not. Perhaps the taboo is so great. Yeah. But no, I don't think so. But in general, I think there's a sense that this is an absolute watershed. It is clear now beyond the slightest shadow of a doubt that there is nothing that the Nazis are not prepared to do to the Jews. And whatever they do do, nobody will try to stop them. Well, except Dominic, there is still a shadow of a doubt, isn't there? Because, I mean, no one at this stage, even now, is thinking that there might be industrialised extermination of Jews. That's fair, but it's plausible that they will organise pogrom after pogrom.
也许没有。也许禁忌太大了。是的。但没有，我不这么认为。但总的来说，我认为这绝对是一个分水岭。现在毫无疑问，纳粹准备对犹太人做任何事情。无论他们做什么，没有人会试图阻止他们。嗯，除了多米尼克，仍然有一丝怀疑，不是吗？因为，我的意思是，在这个阶段，即使是现在，也没有人认为可能会对犹太人进行工业化的灭绝。这很公平，但他们组织一次又一次的大屠杀是合理的。
I mean, it's very clear they are committed to this idea about driving the Jews out of Germany. I said there were many terrible things. Another terrible thing, on the 10th of November, just a day or so later, the Nazis meet to decide who's going to pay for all this. And they decide, well, the Jews will pay for it. They'll pay for it themselves. So on the 12th, Goering announces the economic measures
我的意思是，很明显他们致力于将犹太人赶出德国的想法。我说过有很多可怕的事情。另一件可怕的事情是，在11月10日，仅仅一天左右之后，纳粹开会决定谁来为这一切买单。他们决定，嗯，犹太人会买单。他们会自己买单。所以在12日，戈林宣布了经济措施
that will be promulgated against the Jews. He says they will pay a fine for the damage that was inflicted upon them of one billion Reichsmarks. Every Jewish family will have to hand over a quarter of their assets in order to pay for the damage. There is a law on the exclusion of Jews from German economic life. So you can't basically hold any meaningful occupation anymore if you're Jewish in Germany. All remaining Jewish businesses, there aren't many left,
将针对犹太人颁布。他说他们将为所受的损害支付10亿帝国马克的罚款。每个犹太家庭都必须交出其资产的四分之一来支付赔偿。有一项关于将犹太人排除在德国经济生活之外的法律。所以如果你是德国的犹太人，你基本上不能再从事任何有意义的职业了。所有剩下的犹太企业，没剩下多少了，
but they will be area-nised. You know, they will be taken over by non-Jews. They will basically be completely segregated now. This is terrible in Victor Klemperer's diaries, isn't it? He finds himself excluded
但它们将被雅利安化。你知道，它们将被非犹太人接管。它们基本上现在将被完全隔离。这在维克多·克莱姆佩雷尔的日记里很可怕，不是吗？他发现自己被排除在
from everything. It's terrible. Everything. Can't go to the cinema, can't go to the theatre, can't go to a concert, can't go to a swimming pool. A town now has the right to ban you from certain streets from certain parts of the town you cannot drive you cannot go to a park you cannot go to a sports facility you cannot go to any swimming pool hydric suggests at this point that they should wear
一切之外。这太可怕了。一切。不能去电影院，不能去剧院，不能去音乐会，不能去游泳池。城镇现在有权禁止你进入某些街道，某些城镇区域，你不能开车，你不能去公园，你不能去体育设施，你不能去任何游泳池。海德里希此时建议他们应该佩戴
badges yellow badges but that is not fully introduced actually until the second world war. But in a sense, it's irrelevant because at this point the Jews have been driven into virtual ghetto, I suppose. But also a bureaucratic ghetto. Yes. Because their names are on public record. Yeah, of course. I mean, they've got the J stamps in their passport. They've been renamed, Tom. So some people do get out, 80,000 people or so. They go to USA. Some go to Britain.
徽章，黄色徽章，但这实际上直到第二次世界大战才完全引入。但在某种意义上，这无关紧要，因为此时犹太人已经被赶进了虚拟的隔都，我想。但也进入了一个官僚隔都。是的。因为他们的名字在公共记录上。是的，当然。我的意思是，他们的护照上有J印章。他们被重新命名了，汤姆。所以有些人确实逃出去了，大约8万人。他们去了美国。有些人去了英国。
Some go to Holland until the Dutch close their borders. Some go to Brazil or Argentina or Shanghai, actually, a disproportionately high number given its size, go to the free port of Shanghai, which has some of the laxest or most welcoming, shall we say, rules anywhere in the world about the admission of Jews. Britain doesn't. Britain really puts up the barrier. But having said that, is this when the Kindertransport happens? Yeah, 10,000 or so Jewish children come to Britain. But yes, no European state says, you can all come here. Actually, most European neighbors are more anxious to try and keep out flows of refugees.
有些人去了荷兰，直到荷兰关闭边境。有些人去了巴西或阿根廷或上海，实际上，考虑到其规模，比例非常高，去了上海自由港，那里对犹太人的准入规则可以说是世界上最宽松或最受欢迎的。英国没有。英国真的竖起了障碍。但话虽如此，这是“儿童撤离”发生的时候吗？是的，大约1万名犹太儿童来到英国。但是是的，没有欧洲国家说，你们都可以来这里。实际上，大多数欧洲邻国更急于试图阻止难民涌入。
So about 80,000 people have left, but from the Nazi point of view, that is not enough. They have played their card, this huge pogrom, and there are still tens and tens of thousands of Jewish people left in Germany. So the question now is what will they do? And a couple of months later, the beginning of 1939, there is set up under Reinhard Heydrich a central office for Jewish immigration. This is the office that has been given the responsibility of, in inverted commas, removing the remaining Jewish population of Germany from the Reich and implicitly from Europe. And as Ian Kershaw says, this is a decisive step on the way that was to end in the gas chambers of the extermination camps, because it is this commission, it is this post that Heydrich invokes when he opens the Wannsee Conference in January 1942.
所以大约有8万人离开了，但从纳粹的角度来看，这还不够。他们打出了这张牌，这场巨大的大屠杀，德国仍然有成千上万的犹太人。所以现在的问题是他们会做什么？几个月后，1939年初，在莱因哈德·海德里希的领导下成立了犹太移民中央办公室。这个办公室被赋予了责任，用引号来说，将德国剩余的犹太人口从帝国中移除，并隐含地从欧洲移除。正如伊恩·克肖所说，这是通往最终在灭绝营毒气室结束的道路上的决定性一步，因为正是这个委员会，正是这个职位，海德里希在1942年1月召开万湖会议时援引了它。
He says, I was given this job at the beginning of 1939 to get rid of the remaining Jews, and this is now what we're about to do. So this is the bureaucratization and the industrialization of genocide. Exactly right. Exactly. And I think Kristallnacht, for the reputation of Germany in the world, to anybody who had deluded themselves about the Nazi regime and its intentions, by the end of 1938, it is absolutely clear. I mean, that editorial in the Yorkshire Post, I found online a selection, a sort of digest of British newspaper editorials reacting to this, and across the political spectrum. So you've got on the right, the Telegraph, the Express, the Mail, and on the left, you have the Manchester Guardian or whatever.
他说，我在1939年初被赋予了这项工作，以摆脱剩余的犹太人，这就是我们现在要做的事情。所以这就是种族灭绝的官僚化和工业化。完全正确。完全正确。我认为水晶之夜，对于德国在世界上的声誉，对于任何对自己欺骗过纳粹政权及其意图的人来说，到1938年底，这绝对是清楚的。我的意思是，那篇《约克郡邮报》的社论，我在网上找到了一份精选，一种对英国报纸社论反应的摘要，跨越了政治光谱。所以你在右翼有《每日电讯报》、《快报》、《邮报》，在左翼有《曼彻斯特卫报》等等。
Across the political spectrum, the utter revulsion at Kristallnacht and what it represents, you know, it's very profound. Yeah, no one can argue about this anymore. Which in turn, Dominic, must mean that in the democracies, the hopes that appeasement will keep war at bay are starting to go into abeyance and retreat. Yeah, I think that's right. And in Germany, therefore, when their ambassadors report this, their certainty that war is coming goes up even further. And the implications of that for German Jews, again, is only bad. Terrifying. Because the closer war comes, the more urgent the Nazi sense that they have to be eliminated.
跨越政治光谱，对水晶之夜及其所代表的一切的彻底厌恶，你知道，这是非常深刻的。是的，没有人能再争论这一点了。这反过来，多米尼克，一定意味着在民主国家，绥靖政策能阻止战争的希望开始搁置和退缩。是的，我认为那是对的。因此在德国，当他们的大使报告这一点时，他们对战争即将来临的确定性进一步提高。这对德国犹太人的影响，再次，只有坏处。太可怕了。因为战争越近，纳粹认为他们必须被消灭的紧迫感就越强。
Absolutely. Because one thing we haven't mentioned, of course, is that this happens in the aftermath of Munich. So Hitler has taken the Sudetenland from Czechoslovakia. It is clear that he is not going to moderate his ambitions. You know, the world has come very close to war now in the autumn of 1938. People were relieved in Britain and France when that was averted by the appeasement of Munich. But I think a lot of people now think a reckoning is coming. And Hitler certainly thinks that a reckoning is coming. I think what you get from Ian Kershaw's biography is a sense that in his own mind at the end of 1938, those two things that have always been interfused, which is the question of the Jewish population in Germany and his thirst for an apocalyptic showdown in Europe, that those two things now loom larger than ever before. There is even a kind of darker tinge to that, which is that even as Hitler is looking forward to war, planning for war, bringing war about, he is still kind of blaming it on the
绝对。因为我们当然没有提到的一件事是，这发生在慕尼黑协议之后。所以希特勒从捷克斯洛伐克夺取了苏台德地区。很明显，他不会缓和他的野心。你知道，在1938年秋天，世界现在非常接近战争。当慕尼黑的绥靖政策避免了战争时，英国和法国的人们感到宽慰。但我认为很多人现在认为清算即将来临。希特勒当然认为清算即将来临。我认为你从伊恩·克肖的传记中得到的是一种感觉，即在1938年底他自己的脑海中，那两件一直融合在一起的事情，即德国犹太人口问题和他对欧洲末日决战的渴望，这两件事现在比以往任何时候都显得更加突出。甚至有一种更黑暗的色彩，那就是即使希特勒在展望战争，计划战争，引发战争，他仍然在某种程度上将其归咎于
Jews, isn't he? Oh, yes. That it is the Jews who will be responsible if war breaks out, even as he is ordering his troops to prepare for invasions. Yeah. In his own mind, I guess, everything that he's doing is reactive. All his preparations for war have been provoked and partly provoked by what happened in 1918. So in January 1939, he has a meeting with the Czechoslovakian foreign minister. He says to him, if there is a war, the Jews here will be annihilated. The Jews didn't bring about the 9th of November 1918 for nothing. This day will be avenged.
犹太人，不是吗？哦，是的。即使在他命令军队准备入侵时，如果战争爆发，犹太人也将负责。是的。在他自己的脑海里，我想，他所做的一切都是被动的。他所有的战争准备都是被挑衅的，部分是被1918年发生的事情所挑衅的。所以在1939年1月，他与捷克斯洛伐克外交部长会面。他对他说，如果发生战争，这里的犹太人将被消灭。犹太人不是白白带来1918年11月9日的。这一天将被复仇。
And there's this sort of sense, I think, as we enter 1939, that Hitler now feels that the moment of vengeance is almost upon him. Vengeance against the French and the Allies and the Poles and all of these people, but also vengeance on what he sees as the enemy within. We'll just end with this. On 30th of January 1939, it's the sixth anniversary at the moment he became Reich Chancellor. So the sixth anniversary of the kind of Nazis' new order in Germany. And he gives a speech to the Reichstag to mark it.
当我们进入1939年时，有一种感觉，我想，希特勒现在觉得复仇的时刻几乎到了。对法国人、盟军、波兰人和所有这些人复仇，但也对他所认为的内部敌人复仇。我们以此结束。1939年1月30日，是他成为帝国总理的六周年纪念日。所以是纳粹在德国建立新秩序的六周年纪念日。他在国会发表了演讲来纪念它。
And this speech is covered in full by the newsreels. And he makes this horrendous prediction. He says, I have very often in my lifetime been a prophet and I was derided. He says, you know, back in the old days, I used to prophesy that I would take over the leadership of Germany and I would deal with the Jewish problem. And the Jews used to laugh at me and they're not laughing anymore. And he says, I want today to be a prophet again. If international finance jury inside and outside Europe should succeed in plunging the nations
这段演讲被新闻短片完整报道。他做出了这个可怕的预言。他说，我一生中经常成为先知，但我被嘲笑了。他说，你知道，在过去的日子里，我曾经预言我会接管德国的领导权，我会处理犹太问题。犹太人过去常嘲笑我，他们不再笑了。他说，我今天想再次成为先知。如果欧洲内外的国际金融犹太势力成功地再次将各国
once again into a world war. See, again, as you say, Tom, he's blaming them. Yeah, it's blaming the Jews. The result will not be the Bolshevization of the earth and thereby the victory of Jewry. He says the result will be the annihilation of the Jewish race in Europe. And Tom, as everybody listening to this podcast will know, he had every intention of delivering on that prophecy. Well, thank you, Dominic. That brings this episode and the series to a close. Terrible,
卷入世界大战。看，再次，正如你所说，汤姆，他在责怪他们。是的，他在责怪犹太人。结果不会是地球的布尔什维克化，从而导致犹太势力的胜利。他说结果将是欧洲犹太种族的灭绝。汤姆，正如听这个播客的每个人都知道的那样，他完全打算实现那个预言。好吧，谢谢你，多米尼克。这使这一集和本系列结束。可怕的，
terrible story and there is much more, of course, still to be told. The onset of war in Europe, the course of the war, the final destruction of Nazi Germany, but that is all to come. For now, we hope you enjoyed the series. Maybe not the right word, but thank you for listening to it. And Dominic, I guess we'll be picking up this story again, hopefully next January.
可怕的故事，当然还有更多的事情要讲。欧洲战争的爆发，战争的进程，纳粹德国的最终毁灭，但这些都还在后面。现在，我们希望你喜欢这个系列。也许不是合适的词，但谢谢你收听它。多米尼克，我想我们希望明年一月能再次开始这个故事。
But until then, and until the next shows, which will be next week, and hopefully on a slightly jollier theme, we'll see you. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde.
但在此之前，直到下周的下一场演出，希望是在一个稍微愉快一点的主题上，我们再见。再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。